we are now going to go further in our
study of the evolution of the empires in
asia and in this video we're going to
focus on what happens in north india
persia the middle east and the anatolian
peninsula what we would consider modern
day turkey
so right here is roughly what asia
looked like around the year 1300. as you
might remember from previous videos as
we entered into the 13th century you
have genghis khan or genghis khan take
over much of asia from mongolia but by
the time you get to 1300 the empire has
fragmented into these various khanates
the wan dynasty in china
chagatai khanate in central asia the
golden horde in northwest asia and the
ilkanit in
persia and the middle east now two
things to keep note of as we look at
this map that are relevant to this video
is notice this tiny little kingdom right
over here this is one of the many
fragmented kingdoms that result
after
the sultanate of rum collapses in the
middle of the 13th century this kingdom
in particular is founded by someone by
the name of usman or the arabic version
of the name would be utman or atman and
so this is the nascent ottoman empire
forming right over here
now over here you have the delhi
sultanate which was the first
significant muslim empire over north
india and notably they were one of the
few empires that were able to fend off
the mongols but now let's fast forward
roughly 100 years
now a few things have changed the ming
dynasty has taken over the wan dynasty
in the middle of the 14th century the
mongols in the east are now relegated to
the northern wan dynasty but there still
is the shakatai khanate and the golden
horde but much of their territory
including the ill khanate has now been
taken over by timur who we talk about in
previous videos and timur famously
sacked delhi and really brought the
delhi sultanate to its knees and as we
will see it will only last for roughly
another hundred years now you might also
notice that the ottoman empire founded
by usman or utman is continuing to grow
and continuing to conquer
now one thing to keep in mind in
previous videos we talk about the
invention of gun powder in tang china
and the early song dynasty which was
about four to five hundred years before
the period that we're talking about
right now but as we get into this period
we are now starting to see the use of
gun powder for guns and in particular
artillery and when i say artillery think
cannons so let's fast forward another
200 years to see how the empires of asia
have evolved
so now we see several things the ming
dynasty is still in control of much of
china the northern wan are still in
mongolia you have a kazakh khanate
descendant from the mongols by the late
16th and early 17th century the ottoman
empire has now expanded significantly
encompassing much of the middle east
in persia
you see that the timarid empire fell
within a few decades after the death of
timur and as we entered into the 16th
century you have the safavid dynasty
take over and then also in the 16th
century almost coincident with the
founding of the safavid dynasty in
persia you have timur's
grandson's great-grandson babur who's
born in current day uzbekistan is able
to defeat the delhi sultanate and
establish the mughal empire and mogul is
just the persian word for mongol and
babur is a direct descendant of timur on
his father's side and of genghis khan on
his mother's side
now many historians often group these
three empires or dynasties together
because they do share some commonalities
and so let's think about each of them
individually and think about where they
are similar and where they are different
not a lot is known about usman who
founds that first kingdom in the
anatolian peninsula it's a sunni islamic
empire in fact the leader is eventually
named a caliph the ruling class of this
empire is turkish now one of their
distinguishing characteristics
is what's known as the devsharma system
in which the sultan the emperor would
have a personal army of what could be
called slaves these janissaries these
janissaries were actually christian boys
taken at a young age and then
indoctrinated into the janissary system
the reason why i said you can kind of
call them slaves is that although they
were forced to become janissaries and
taken from their families they were
given many privileges and over time many
of these janissaries became some of the
most notable figures in the ottoman
empire some of them even becoming the
grand viziere effectively ruling over
the empire
now the ottomans are also known for one
of the earliest empires to very
successfully to use gunpowder in battle
the safavids as you can see here were
really founded in the very early 16th
century officially 1501 by their founder
shah ismail sometimes known as ismail
the first and he is the heir to a
religious dynasty the safavias it is a
muslim dynasty like the ottoman empire
but unlike the ottoman empire it is
based on twelver shia islam
twelver shia is the major group of shias
today
and it is based on the belief of twelve
imams following muhammad starting with
ali and we have videos on the sunni shia
split now even though ismael spoke
turkish and was raised in a turkic
society this dynasty brought back much
of the culture of ancient persia in fact
it's viewed as the first dynasty since
the sassanids that actually had native
persian rule and brought back that
persian culture part of which is using
the word shah you remember cyrus the
great the shah and shah the king of
kings now they had what is known as
gulams which is very similar to the idea
of a janissary these are slave soldiers
which are taken as captives but then are
raised to be an elite military unit and
eventually often have significant wealth
and significant power
now you might be wondering why did any
of these empires and these aren't the
only ones you have the mom looks in
other muslim empires
why would people create these elite
soldiers out of slaves and give them
that much power well the answer is
they were the safest people to give
power to remember these empires are
ruling over many tribes and many groups
and many kingdoms that are constantly
vying for power trying to establish
their own dynasties and if you allowed
people from those various tribes to
protect you as emperor well there might
be a good shot that one of them might
want to kill you and establish their own
dynasty
but from a young age if you could
indoctrinate these young boys as gulams
or as janissaries well they might be
more loyal to you and indeed it did
provide an unusual amount of stability
as i mentioned the mogul empire was able
to be founded by
bobber who was timor's great-grandson's
grandson and he too was born in a turco
mongolian tradition as he's able to
famously defeat the delhi sultanate
which is which was had already been
significantly weakened one on its own
but then
by timur over a hundred years before he
famously comes to power with the aid of
gunpowder being able to defeat a
significantly larger delhi sultanate
army the moguls practiced sunni islam
but they ruled over a large hindu
majority and so the first several mogul
rulers were actually quite tolerant
perhaps the most tolerant was akbar
often known as akbar the great who will
do other videos on who actually tried to
create a religion which was a merger
between islam and hinduism and jainism
and christianity but then they become
less tolerant under shah jahan and
aurangzeb shah jahan famous for building
the taj mahal for his wife but what's
often not noted is he was building this
fairly grand mausoleum at a time when
there was a famine in india and he was
also known as being fairly intolerant
and persecuted many hindus and sikhs and
his son aurangzeb continued to do so
now some historians will refer to these
three empires as the gunpowder empires
if someone says gunpot or empires
they're referring to these three the
reason why they're called that is this
view that these major centralized
empires were able to form only with the
power of gunpowder the ottomans famous
for early use of artillery the moguls
bobber in particular came to power with
gunpowder but today historians are
somewhat skeptical of grouping just
these three empires as gunpowder empires
you had many other large centralized
empires form before the use of gunpowder
so that whole thesis is not as popular
today